- Okay, wow, okay, I'm
surprised I'm hosting this.
All right,
(Malik laughs)
so guys, this is a really big honor,
it's a really big honor for me.
Gary, thank you for hosting
us in VaynerMedia offices.
- Of course.
- I'm from Israel.
- Yes.
- Been in China for the last
10 years with my family.
My father is also here,
I brought him especially
for this amazing encounter with you.
And also my really good friend, Malik.
We are so-called hustlers in China.
- [Gary] Yes.
- We are content creators,
for the last two, three years,
we've been hardcore inside
the social medias in China.
We've been making content
on different levels,
different types, we've been
getting a lot of views,
getting a lot of directions,
we're showing the world
what it's like to live in China,
and this has been our like main passion.
Now we came here to
meet you Gary, because--
- When you say hustlers, are you...
you're KOLs in the marketplace?
- [Malik] Yes.
- But you're also trying
to build outside of it
for people to view in?
- [Malik] Business, hmm-mm.
- Exactly, so our platform's
called, in English it's called,
our platform that we set up is Ychina.
Personally, I'm a KOL, but
I'm running a media business
that creates video shows online.
- [Gary] I understand.
- Yes, I'm not purely a KOL,
Malik is a pure massive KOL
from China, in China, I'm
more like a platform builder
creating shows, working with
different like Tencents,
and Ichi and Yoko, and also
doing shows on the whiteboard.
- You're a production company-
- Currently production.
- within those environments?
- [Raz] Exactly.
- I understand.
- That's exactly what we are.
And then we're here to talk
about, we've got a few really
hot Chinese topics that
relate to the life,
the internet sphere, we
really want to have you
back and forth talking to you about it.
- [Gary] Let's do it.
- So I'll be your host
because it's four topics.
And first of all, maybe
I'll let Malik and my father
introduce themselves as well,
- [Gary] That'd be amazingly.
- Quickly, go ahead.
- Yeah, so my name is Malik
and I actually studied here
at Rutgers in New Jersey, but
I'm also, I'm a KOL in China.
So I create contents about
the American cultures,
but also some personal views on things
on some social issues,
and I have my full--
- Both American and Chinese.
- Yeah, both.
Yeah, I speak Chinese and English.
And I actually came to the
country like four years ago.
So I had a lot of different experience,
I wanted to share with the youth in China.
So that's how I started my channel
and built a million
followers in six months.
- [Gary] On Weibo?
- Yeah, on Weibo, and before that,
I was watching your stuff,
and it was a huge inspiration for me.
- Thank you.
- Just being out there,
and just hustle and work hard, so.
- [Gary] Awesome.
- [Raz] That's amazing, yeah, good.
- Yeah for me.
- Paps.
I met paps already in the
elevator, we had a very nice chat.
- [Paps] Timing is everything.
- Everything.
(all laugh)
- Tinming is everything, so about timing,
we felt the timing is right
to go to China in 2003.
- [Gary] What was it,
were you in a business or?
- Venture capitalists, as you may think.
So venture capitalist is
supposed to see the future.
- [Gary] 100%.
- But actually don't go too far away.
- [Gary] That's exactly right.
- Find the right--
- I'm aware.
- Metrics of this, I mean,
you've got the background,
obviously, so you know it well.
We feel that China is around
the corner business wise,
venture capital, technology,
innovation, this kind of stuff.
And you know Israel is good to this shit.
- [Gary] Yes, very good.
How old was Raz when you guys
moved, how old are you Raz?
- I am 23 this year.
- So you were 13?
- And I was 13 when we
moved, but he entered 2003,
when I was seven years old,
that's where he started
doing stuff in China.
- We did the first fun in 2004.
- And you were flying back and forth,
and then finally decided?
- Yeah.
- Yeah, when we saw it's real,
it's not the only, it just a dream.
- [Gary] It's not emerging, it's here.
- It's here, it's here and now,
and then you have to
shovel down, triple down,
force down on it, and
the only way to do it
is move your family--
- Was that tough for you though?
- Huh, it's tough, I have
three younger siblings.
They're all smarter than me,
we couldn't speak a
word of English actually
'cause in Israel, we studied
Hebrew and the English level
of people of local people is very bad, so.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
(mumbles)
- He took us, he put us threw
us in the school in Hong Kong
at the beginning and then
later in Beijing, it was tough.
But I think that was made us
like that really brought us
to this,
- Close.
- So close as culture, I'm so
close to the Chinese culture
in so many levels and it's
really opening your world.
And many people don't really
understand the way I think
or do things because so early
on I left my Israeli friends,
I didn't go to the army
yet, which is a shame yet,
but I still go back, he's a
pilot, 24 years, he was a pilot.
It's been a tough culture shock for me,
back in Israel, how I didn't
really serve in the army,
but here in China, I'm
a foreigner, so cool.
But I think giving this
platform, social media,
and this ability to express
myself and build a company,
and that the media would gave me a place
to kind of find myself--
- [Gary] Of course.
- In China, and I'm
trying to push it forward.
Sadly, we've been in China many years,
but he can always speak Chinese.
I can speak Chinese, he got
all his children speak Chinese
and then, but he understands
Chinese people, I think more
than anyone could in many ways.
So yeah, this is our little family story.
- [Gary] I love it, so interesting.
- It's all right, so we have,
we brought some topics, Gary.
- [Gary] Let's go.
- So look, we really want
people to know you in China,
and we want, you have
a lot of philosophies,
ways you do things that
really can spell a generation
of Chinese people.
Now, there's so many things
we're gonna talk about
starting from the culture
of the nineties in China,
all the way to the e-gaming
in China, which is huge now,
all the way to, we're talking
about the social family
pressures that Chinese
common families have,
which is a big thing on the way.
- Which is really problem,
if you asked me intuitively
what I'm most excited
about in the next decade
as I start building my
brand and my opportunities
within mainland China and culture,
and Southeast Asia in general,
it is the family dynamic,
because that is the most
interesting insight that I've seen
from afar for the little
homework that I've done.
It's just a real, and listen,
being a Jewish Eastern
European immigrant in the US,
similar but different.
It's always a dynamic, but
it is extremely aggressive
in mainland China, and it's
funny you bring that up,
because that is absolutely,
I mean, the next book
I'm thinking about writing is perfectly,
it's called "Perfectly Parented."
It's a parenting book for
entrepreneurs and more about,
your dad understands Chinese people
only because he deploys empathy.
- Sure, that's true, 100% true.
By the way, the fact we
pick this family issue
is the most interesting
thing because I've talked to
so many foreigners about China,
I haven't seen one touch that.
- That's the only thing,
it's the key point, anyway--
- We got the Malik over here.
- Sorry to interrupt.
- He's pure Chinese, he
looks like his family values
and stuff.
(paps laughs)
But then the fourth topic we'll
go into just talking about
this (indistinct), which means
like the three philosophies
of Chinese people, how they
see political correctness.
We'll get a better at the end.
- Interesting.
- Very interesting actually,
that he also has a lot
to say about this, so let's,
- [Gary] Let's go.
- Hear the first.
So first of all, we are this,
we represent this really huge,
large, young audience
of Chinese people that
are seeking this kind of
culture interaction with people
around the world, willing to
learn the culture of New York,
they're willing to learn
culture of America,
culture around the world,
and willing for foreigners
to learn their culture, it's
a really interesting age.
However, there is this
phenomenon coming up in China
these days that people in
China see themselves as the
(indistinct) in Chinese,
which means their Buddhist lifestyle.
My question is, first
of all, young people,
'90s millennials taking life as like
everything will come to
them in this generation
because we have some technologies,
so much internet, so much things,
is that the right approach
that people should take?
That's a big part of that--
- I don't think it's
as wrong of an approach
as many may think I
think given my obsession
that hard work is a pillar
of variable success.
I'll explain why, first of
all, you have to understand
that it's a very common
theme when Nations or people
start going through prosperity.
This is not something you can stop.
When people talk about
American millennials,
when you talk about 60 years
of success in a country,
nothing, no real negative drivers,
that's naturally what's going to happen.
Of course, older Chinese,
the parents and grandparents
of those kids look at them with cynicism
because they lived in a much
more difficult environment.
I think that optimism is
what makes America America.
I think optimism is extremely powerful.
I think optimism and entitlement
are a very dangerous fine line.
So the answer is as a
whole, I actually love it.
I'm massively optimistic
and I generally believe
everything's going to be okay.
And I'm very team human being,
I think humans are very underrated.
When it starts falling into entitlement or
if you look at what's
happening in Saudi Arabia,
which I think is an interesting parallel,
it's about to go through
a very interesting period
with its new reforms, it's
basically people have a state,
the state's taking care of everything.
- [paps] Sure.
- I was born in communist
Soviet Russia, right,
Soviet Union, so I have a lot of empathy.
My parents are a little bit different,
but a lot of my parents'
friends really struggled
when they came to America
because they won the lottery
in the Soviet Union and had
easy jobs, AKA doing nothing,
and the state would take care of it.
So I think when you lay a
technology on top of it,
which means they can touch everything.
Honestly, I think it's
good comma, a lot of people
will get sucked into not
doing anything, thus losing.
- [paps] True.
- As long as you can get
anybody in that generation
to understand nobody is
successful in being successful
in life without putting in
hard work, they may inherit.
Somebody could be wealthy
without putting in hard work.
It's because their mommy and
daddy gave them the money.
But nobody is successful,
nobody is successful
without putting in the work,
including athletes or mo...
I like using models, a lot
of people are born pretty.
- [paps] True.
- But putting in the work
to learn how to translate to
a camera, understanding which
platforms have the attention,
whether that's Sports
Illustrated or Instagram,
like it's just work.
Like you look at the supermodels
of the last 20 years,
a lot of those women
are hardcore hustlers.
That's why they've all had very
good entrepreneurial careers
after, we get tricked
because they're beautiful,
but they're putting in work.
And so as long as you can
deliver to that generation,
that work is an essential pillar of this
optimistic point of view,
if that's what you want,
success and things, great, by the way,
if you just want to be happy,
I think it's a great outlook.
To me, the only thing that
bothers me or causes me caution,
is when people think things come to them
without putting in the work,
that's all, it's a very simple.
You can't get muscles without working out,
and you can't get success without working.
And there's a lot of people
that push back at me,
especially in Europe and
more liberal points of view
around too much work it's
'cause they're not listening to
what's coming out of my mouth.
My words are very simple,
as long as your work ethic
matches your ambition, you are very happy.
Meaning if you want to have
a nice work life balance
and have three days off
a week and be healthy,
and what have you, and recognize
that you're not going to
have mansions or reputation
or books or, great.
I mean, I think that's, to be very frank,
there's a lot of times I
wish that was my ambition.
To me the only stress in the system,
is when people's ambition, AKA their mouth
doesn't match their actions.
There's a lot of people
in on Weibo and Instagram,
and YouTube saying that they're
going to be billionaires,
they're going to rule the world,
who go to 45 music festivals a year,
(all laugh)
and that is not going to happen.
So to me, it's just matching
your ambition to your actions.
Otherwise, I think it's a great thing
that people are optimistic
because I think optimism matters.
- Okay, Malik, what did you want to say?
- Yeah, to elaborate about
the Buddhist lifestyle,
so it's also the young people nowadays.
They think that they're
facing more challenges in like
a more competitive environment
than their parents,
because they have to
learn much more stuff,
they have to have much more skills,
going to college doesn't
guarantee anything at all.
- [Gary] They're right, they're right.
- So--
- [Gary] But the problem is
they're thinking about it
through their parents' eyes.
- Yeah, and also like with almost,
like this much of competition.
- Do you understand though?
- Yeah.
- Like college, to your point,
especially in mainland China
and high net worth into it,
the path of college then
sets you up is over.
- [Malik] Yeah.
- It's over.
- [Malik] It doesn't
guarantee you anything.
- It's just over, like,
look, if you want to work
at Bain and McKinsey and Goldman
Sachs, big time education,
you can still have that
path, that's great.
- [Mallik] I agree.
- Nothing wrong with that.
The problem is the default
that a college education,
the pedals were off the rows.
Like it's outside of the
elite top 10 schools,
I think the schools that
are most dangerous are
schools 25 to 100, because
they had some brand
but they don't translate.
They don't translate in
today's reality anymore.
It just doesn't matter,
and for a parent at home,
especially in mainland China,
this is back to what I jumped on,
I am very upset that you have
one child, to your point.
And I don't know every detail,
but I'm aware enough to know
a lot of people are single children.
(Malik laughs)
The thing that I see
common in Southeast culture
and especially in mainland China,
is that for a lot of parents,
their kid is a representation of them,
and that's where it breaks.
- [Malik] Exactly.
- And that's where it breaks in Israel,
and in breaks in Belarus,
and breaks in America.
It breaks if a parent thinks
that a kid's accomplishment
is a reflection on them, because
now you have a disconnect.
Now you're not a parent and a child,
you're a person with a product.
And I think that that is scary to me.
- True.
- Because going to Harvard
or Stanford or Yale is a badge
that people back in Beijing
walk around proudly to
their contemporaries,
and they're fucking their kids up.
- That's a word though
to use, that's so sure.
- That's it, that's the breakdown.
So, but the kids are right.
Here's what I would say
to the kids, "Too bad."
(Malik laughs)
I mean too bad that it's hard now.
Like you have a lot of
things going for you too.
I promise you right now,
all of you would not switch
with your grandparents.
- [Malik] Yeah.
- If you're in China and
you're listening right now,
and you have the option of
having not college set you up
so easily, or be your grandparents
and live in that communist
China, I have a funny feeling
you're going to choose this.
(Malik laughs)
So to me, I have empathy
that it's different
and I've empathy that you've
been told education, education,
education, college, college,
college, good college,
get straight A's, straight
A's, alpha, alpha dragon, drag,
I understand, it's changed
but you're not going to switch
with your grandparents, so
what are you crying about?
- [Raz] True.
- Life's about alternatives.
- [Raz] That's true.
- It's less about alternative.
So what do you want, you
want to, what do you want?
And I think most people
realize how good they have it.
And so yes, it's changed,
yes, there's new difficulties,
but it's so much better
than it used to be,
and so I can't get upset for
anybody who's living through,
"Oh, darn it, my Yale
education is not going to
take care of me," especially
when a far bigger percentage
of kids from mainland China that are going
to these universities are
having it paid for by their
parents than the alternative
of a lot of Americans, so.
- One thing is in Mainland
China, that is an optimism.
It's a very optimistic point of view is,
the government is now
encouraging graduates
to take entrepreneurship
as their first job.
And we see in Beijing
especially (mumbles).
Graduates who used to
go to the government of
the big companies to follow
what their parents think,
they open their own startups,
they're doing start ups.
The parents have nothing to say about it
because the government endorsed it.
So it's kind of--
- I think that's great, look, America wins
because of entrepreneurship.
It's offense, you're either
an offense or defense.
Europe's been on defense for 50 years,
that's why Europe sucks
on the global stage
of competitive business, I love Europe.
I love Europe for one,
I was born in Europe.
I love Europe for culture,
I like the kindness
and the empathy, I love
Europe for a lot of
its social points of view,
except when it goes too far
to the left, I love Europe,
but Europe can't win.
Europe's soft, and so I think
it's great that China pushes.
And look, I'm an American who
was born in the Soviet Union,
who absolutely believes
that China has one already,
meaning that when I'm an
old man or when I'm gone,
and my grandkids are like,
"China is the superpower."
I really believe that, because
then China runs its country
more like a business, meaning
it's a business, like me.
I give freedom to my team so much,
except on a couple
things that matter to me,
and then it's a dictatorship,
that's more China, right?
So I think China's model in a lot of ways,
I mean, socially forget.
I'm talking about
entrepreneurship and business
and the alpha stuff, I think
China's got a long way to go.
There's soft skills and equal
rights and a million things
that make like, but I
think it'll get there
out of its leadership.
So I think it's sitting very
pretty, I think it's great that
it's pushing kids to entrepreneurship.
My problem is nine out of 10
of these Chinese kids that are
22 year olds that are
jumping into entrepreneurship
have no chance because
they're not entrepreneurs.
- Yes, but that's good
because it's education.
- Yes, but you have to be careful
because the one thing I fear
is when these kids fail,
and almost all of them will,
it's a very big scarlet letter
in that culture, and I
think psychologically,
you're putting a 23 year old
in a very vulnerable spot
where now they have a loss
publicly, there's no hiding.
When you lose in school like
I did, you can blame people.
When Iris loses at
VaynerMedia, she can blame me.
When you work at a company or
when the government's involved
or when at school, you
can blame somebody else.
When you have a business, it's your fault.
And the only thing I would say,
it's already something that
concerns me in America,
where it is not a scarlet
letter to lose in business,
but still, there's an enormous amount of,
because there's so many
fake entrepreneurs now
because everybody's pushing
it, and now you have students
who, I like when I lose, I
like when you guys look at me
and say, "He lost, he did it wrong,"
cause I'm an entrepreneur.
But when you're a
student and you get an F,
it's devastating, so I
would caution one thing
for anybody who's
listening in mainland China
who thinks entrepreneurship
is such a freedom.
When you lose, you have to
make sure that you're mentally
stable enough to be able
to take all that cynicism
and the critiques from everybody,
including your friends,
your friends' parents, your
parents, because if you don't,
you start going down a very
dangerous path that leads to
a very scary place.
We do not reconcile why
we have suicide in America
at the teenage level, it's
because modern parenting
is over coddling kids to an extreme level
where kids don't know how
to deal with adversity.
If you've been a great student
in the mainland China machine
and you now pop out and you start the Uber
or Tencent of dry cleaning and you fail,
I don't want kids to go
into depression and suicide.
I think self-awareness
matters much more than
being an entrepreneur, for you and I,
the learning makes sense, it's our DNA.
I look at every loss as learning.
That is not how people are wired,
so we have to be thoughtful
of, we go too far, right?
It's all college, it's
all entrepreneurship.
We need to find the right
balance of understanding.
We need to do a much better
job, zero to 18, to understand
somebody's makeup, their
emotional makeup, their skillset.
The way we do school today,
and the way we structure
our kids for success in the first 18 years
is so broken worldwide.
And so for me, I'm thinking
a lot about the next 20,
30 years of my life, how
can I impact that least,
to now I impact by putting out content
and getting the 500 DMS I
get every day of, "Thank you,
thank you, thank you, you're
helping me, you're a shield."
That's my first step, but
over time, I'd like to do more
because it is the most important thing.
Because if your parented well,
you can see it from a mile
away and when you're not,
you can see it from a mile away.
And I think too many parents
view their kids as a product.
- Yeah, I have an idea for you may use.
You were said that, right,
it's about what is your target.
If your target is to
win, to go all the way,
you put everything in.
I think we're going to era where there is
like micro innovation,
micro-entrepreneurship.
You don't set your goal to be the next--
- I agree, I agree.
- It's a life lifestyle issue.
I want to be in my lifestyle, okay.
- I agree.
- It's going to be split into
three; machines, lifestyle
and innovation style.
- I agree.
I agree so much, I push it very heavily.
What's wrong with having a
business doing 137,000 a year
and you're very happy selling donuts?
- [Paps] Yes.
- I want it very badly.
The problem is venture capital
and the modern technology media,
everything's about unicorns
and billion dollars.
- Crowdfunding.
Crowdfunding makes it easier,
don't need the venture capitalist.
- You're preaching,
how about a better one?
How about just build a fucking business
and work off your own cashflow?
- [Paps] Good education.
(Gary laughs)
Actually, this is what
we do in some cases.
- I mean, Jesus Christ,
I mean like why not just,
I mean, VaynerMedia is
a $200 billion company.
I raised zero capital,
I sold somebody a $60,000 consulting gig.
I was in a different place in my career,
but I still could have raised it.
Like learning how to make
money is the number one skill.
Sell something, Singles Day
sells trillions of dollars
of shit every year, figure it out,
get your $100 out of it, Jesus.
And I mean this, I want to
teach kids more to learn
how to make money versus raising money,
because that's a skill
that never goes away.
You can always raise money later.
And he'll tell you it's a
lot easier to raise money
when you're making money, (laughs).
All right, let's keep moving.
- That's interesting, okay,
so just you're talking
about failure and winning,
and then you here have two
23-year olds who I think you
understand young people's
mentality or what they
need to do much more than
we understand ourselves in some way.
- [Malik] I'm surprised,
like Gary knows so much
that is going on in
China without actually--
- Yeah, that's incredible.
And so there's one thing I
want to say that Malik and I
we know quite well as
being, living in China
and engaging in the internet is that,
there is this massive
thing going on in China
that's adding to the Buddhist mentality
is that people take on
their time to play games.
- [Gary] Yes.
- [Malik] Video games.
- E-games.
- [Gary] Sure.
- It's a mobile country,
it's completely mobilized.
Everyone plays on their phone.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- And the last two or three years,
you've seen like huge companies,
like Tencents and Wong,
they've bought companies
all around the world plus
developing their own
Chinese style companies,
like taking Dota and League
Of Legends, making it in the
Kings Of Honor, which is
very popular social e-gaming.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- And you're talking about
different types of games
that include many people playing together.
PGB which is another one,
what I'm saying is that,
most Chinese people, a
lot of their time is spent
even with their parents
during Chinese New Year,
there will be 90% of time playing games.
Playing maybe to look to win
something because it gives them
a belonging, like they feel
like they're winning though.
But the thing is that the see
gaming culture, first of all,
what do you think of young
people being engaged, literally,
most of the time, all the day,
e-gaming all their free time.
- Yeah, I mean, I'm a fan
of it and I'll tell you why.
We've always needed escapism.
- [Malik] True.
- Humans are very basic, we like escapism.
So for me, if you're asking
me if I have to choose back
to life being alternatives,
a 16 year old right now
from 7:00 PM to 11:00 PM at
night in China, playing games
versus watching television,
which is what her or his parents
did 20 years earlier, or
reading a book for information
that is now at their
fingertip, I'll pick gaming
because I think what it's
doing is it's forming behavior
that is far more relevant
to today's society.
As we go into a more
machine-oriented world,
the mathematical structure
around gaming psychology,
the things they learn the
most self-aware will realize
they're getting suckered
into the gamification of it.
They're chasing a carrot, but
we chase a carrot everywhere.
That's that's what humans do.
We're just animals, we're
very easy to understand.
Back to winning, back to winning,
just to bounce a little bit,
I wanted to make a point
and I'll use it right here.
To me, the people that
win the most are the ones
that are addicted to the process
and the game of the life,
much more than the
things they get from it.
- [Malik] Yes, I agree.
- That's the ultimate,
can you love the journey,
the process, the work,
whatever you want to call it?
And to me, it's so important
that in today's option economy,
with all this technology,
when machines take over
all these jobs, I laugh.
They're going to take over all the jobs
that most people don't like doing.
They just do it to get paid,
what they need to pay their
mortgage or to buy things
that cover up their actual sadness.
I can live in a fucking basement with all,
this is true, and I bet you,
my team will agree with this.
I'm a kind of person that
wishes, this was our family,
and we all lived in this room.
It's really funny for me to even say that,
I've never said it that way,
but it made me go right back
to where I started here, not
too far from here in Queens,
in a small room with a lot
of family, like it's fun.
- We work, we live.
- That's it.
So to me, I think it's great,
I'm not going to frown on that
because I think about it,
what would those people
be doing otherwise?
- Sure, no sibling is a big issue.
If you have siblings, you interact more,
so that's a price to pay.
- No question, I think
the one-child variable
is fascinating, my
father's a single child,
my closest cousin,
Bobby, is a single child
and I've always been
fascinated by both of them
in a lot of ways, and I've
always been fascinated,
maybe 'cause I'm very
close to my siblings.
When you were talking, all that
was running through my mind
was, "Oh, that's so good, that means him
and his three siblings got very close
'cause they had each
other in the beginning
when they moved not, much
yet," I think it's, yes.
I think the single-child culture at scale,
we've never seen scale like this.
I don't have real thoughts,
you can see I can talk
very passionate of what I know,
I haven't thought enough about it.
But I think it makes sense that
they gravitate towards that.
But we gravitate towards it
here in the us and Europe
and other, and South America does too.
I think look, humans like
interacting with each other.
It's what we do.
So nobody here is going to tell
me that they don't feel like
they're interacting with somebody
when they're playing games,
when we're texting, when like,
we are, we are, that's
why I love it so much.
- Yeah, I agree, like my younger
brother he's in high school
and all he does during the
weekend he's playing games.
But later I realized all
of his friends are on it.
- He's more social.
- Yeah, it's a way to socialize.
- I say this all the time,
- It's same as we going out.
- Kids are more social now, not less.
- [Malik] Yeah.
- [Raz] Yes.
- I used to sit in my room by myself
because I couldn't go outside and play.
It was 6:00 PM, March,
let me use real life,
January 8th, 1986, I'm in
my home 'cause it got dark.
I was an '80s baby when we played outside,
but now it was dark, it
was cold, I wasn't playing.
And I was like in my
room, which is by the way,
a long time is great too,
I'm sure very valuable.
I'm sure plenty of people are gonna argue
that we have no alone time
anymore, thus we're over.
It's so funny to me, everybody
says our kids don't know how
to engage, they're not social, I'm like,
"They're the reverse,"
they're over social,
they have no downtime.
So to me, I think it's super interesting,
I think gaming is great.
I think most businesses are
going to start layering,
heavy gamification psychology
to everything they do.
If you look at businesses
like Uber and other things
around the world, a lot
of them grew, Spotify,
off of referral, gamification,
I think everything will have
gamification layers on it.
- Yeah, Tencent is a company of gaming.
- Which in itself is a game, (mumbles).
- We getting really
close to watch out policy
because he had to...
- He had to do something, right.
- I want to take this stuff
a little bit deeper because
there's something in China that
I don't know if it's here in
the US because in China
woman play more than men.
It's ridiculous, there's a
high percentage of women--
- I was about to say that point--
- Why is that, yeah?
Or like, what do you think of this,
like of this woman getting involved
'cause usually in my country, in Israel--
- In the US and Israel, and
Europe, you'll see that dynamic
happen in the next 20 years as well.
It's because China was further
along in the mobile culture
and the gamification culture.
You know what happened, similar
what's happening in Africa,
they leapfrogged, like American
women are going to be gaming
at scale and they do, they
already do quietly on mobile
because the games of
America were established far
more males focused, right?
- [Malik] Yeah.
- They were much more male focused.
So that me as a 42-year-old
male growing up,
they were guy games, they were guy games.
You had some games like
Sonic the hedgehog, Mario,
you had it, but in culture,
video games were for boys,
right, and that's just the way it is.
And now that's breaking
down and you'll see.
This is human, gamification
and game escapism is human.
And we see it with Candy
Crush and Angry Birds.
We saw far more, 50-50, 60-40,
once the stigma goes away,
which it, I think it already
has, you'll you'll see far.
I mean, especially now,
you talk to a 12, 13,
14 year old girl, she's
super on board with e-sports
and willing to go there.
And so I don't even think
of it, I think it's just
the timing of how it was
introduced into the marketplace.
I think most things are like that.
Look, pink was a boys'
color in Europe when it was.
When pink was first
introduced it was a boys color
in the 1800s in Western Europe,
so like things get manipulated,
heavy hands get involved.
There's a lot of heavy
hands on a lot of issues.
And I think that's what
happened with gaming in the US
and Europe, but there is
no reason that should be.
And I would even argue that
the most successful e-sports
athletes and gamers in
25 years skew female
as much as it skews male.
- I see.
- And where are you going
with your gaming or your personal life--?
- No, I think look, I
think this is a funny time
to talk about this, whether it's China,
whether it's e-gaming,
whether it's cryptocurrency,
whether it's machine learning,
there are so many trends
that are obvious to me
that are foregone
conclusions in our society.
As much as I've done a good
job in feeling omnipresent
and pumping out a lot, I can
only tackle so many things.
To me, everything I just mentioned,
there will be a time and a
place for me to be involved.
I don't need to be earliest,
I just need to be executing
well in places that matter.
I've not been able to
get around to e-sports
in a meaningful way.
I watch all this stuff very carefully.
I'm building a Twitch studio
right outside my office.
- [Malik] So you have with
three silica coming up?
- Yeah, that would
probably be done in what,
maybe four or five weeks, like April 1st.
(participant mumbles)
Let's say in a month.
- [Malik] And I'm going to be
gaming, you're gonna be gaming
live streaming yourself?
- I'm going to be gaming
with things that I can play.
- [Raz] (chuckles), that'd
be interesting, (mumbles).
- So there's no legal legends
for me, I don't want to.
To me, it's going to be double
dribbled from Nintendo 1986.
Like I'm going to throw
back games, I'm going to.
When people come through,
we would have jumped on for 10 minutes.
I'm going to use it for
attention purposes, blockchain,
all this stuff is stuff I'm
paying very close attention to,
but I'm not deep enough yet
to execute or to speak on it.
I don't like to talk
about things I don't know
unbelievably well, which
is why I talk so much about
something very narrow,
which is consumer behavior
around social layers on the internet.
And I'll get inevitably
in the next three, five,
seven years, one of those
pillars that I just mentioned,
including maybe China.
One of the things I think
a lot about is what happens
when my kids get a little older,
when I can travel with them a little bit?
Like I think about China quite a bit.
China for me is extremely exciting because
I love the journey, I love
that nobody knows me in China.
- So you can just be here
in your normal person
walking around?
- No I can. No, no, no.
I'm never normal.
(all laugh)
No, because I can start
the process of building.
- [Raz] It's a nice, the process.
- [Malik] You enjoy the
process of building (mumbles).
- Finding the right teammates to help me
doing the right things, spending,
the process like going
there and starting at zero
and catching up to
everybody is the ultimate.
- That's amazing, so let's
touch a topic that you said at
the beginning, you really
excited to talk about parenting.
And also I ended up bringing
my father to this talk,
it's exciting, and then you,
as a parent, then in China,
parents is such a, kids
relation with the parents
and the older generation
is very, it's not an issue,
but it's a heavy thing on their life.
And Chinese New Year just
finished where all the kids
had to go back home and deal
with different questions
and pressures of, "What, how's
your job as you're doing,
you're going to get married
like in different places,
in China of different cultures?"
- It's the single biggest
impact of having mainland China.
If you ask me to predict,
going to prediction
in eight or nine years,
I think I will be a very
substantial personality in China
because I have a very strong,
passionate point of view
on this issue that I
don't think is very loved
by the older generation
and I think is adored
by the younger generation
and they need somebody,
just like the American kids
need somebody to point to,
to protect them on these battles.
And I want to be that person.
To me, if you asked me what my
great legacy can be is to be
the voice of somebody who was
parent did extremely well.
I was perfectly parented.
I had parents who had
those same pressures,
who came from those same places,
who refused to treat me that way.
And that's why I'm going to be special.
And I want that for the
good trillions of kids
around the world because they deserve it,
because you're absolutely right.
The fact that 99 out of 100 parents
back in Chinese New Year
put unneeded pressure
on their kids, which ultimately
is going to hurt their
children and hurt their
relationship with their children,
needs to start being eradicated.
We need to change the
conversation on this issue,
and it starts with the
insecurities of the parents.
It's an insecurity on the parent level.
And it's really, you know
what's really interesting to me?
I think of China as such
winners holistically,
'cause what the country's doing,
but it is the ultimate loser
move to think that you are
successful based on what your
children are accomplishing.
I get it, like I take much
more pride in when my kids
are funny or doing
something special, I get it.
I'm starting to really get
it, however, it is just wrong.
It is just absolutely wrong, and so.
- What do you think Malik 'cause you?
- Yeah, to go deeper, there
are a lot of new families
that they're just newly
became the middle class.
So middle class is booming.
So they're afraid that
they're going to lose
because they just got there
and all like that the only way
that they can think of to
maintain the status is to invest
in their kids' education or
push a little bit harder to make
sure their kids can carry on the status.
- [Gary] I get it.
- So that's one pressure.
- They're wrong.
- Yeah, (laughs)
- I understand, they're going to lose.
They're going to lose their
kids and they're going to lose.
They're going to lose their relationship
with their kids over time.
What they don't understand
is how quickly the world is
evolving and how and how we're
all more connected than ever.
And we're all looking at
each other's cultures.
I think the greatest thing that
has ever going to happen to
America is China's emergence.
I think kids that are going
to be born 10 years from now
are going to be winners in
America 40 years from now,
because of the chip on their shoulder
of losing that world-stage leadership.
I really believe that.
I think America is different
than Europe that way.
- So what should parents
invest in their kid
and what aspect, because--
- They should invest in their
emotional and intelligence...
- Soft skills.
- 100%.
- Yeah.
- What should they invest in, listening
and try to figure out their kids.
Your mother is still, you
guys are still married?
They have four children, they
can't raise all four kids
the same way, not to be
ultimately successful.
I mean, he could do whatever he wants.
I don't tell anybody to parent, listen,
I've passionate points of view on this,
but I will never tell anybody
how to parent their child.
That's very personal.
I don't tell anybody how
to have their relationship
with their loved one, their spouse,
these are personal things,
it's one man's point of view.
But it's one man's point
of view that has the luxury
of being an outlier and watching
how everybody else did it.
And then watching it
becoming the formative way
that he looked at the world.
It's how I am as a manager to my team.
There's a reason they like it,
it's because I learned those
skills, I'm a product of it.
And I don't want to be a
hypocrite and treat them
as employees differently
than I was treated.
And they'll tell you, I don't over coddle.
It's not coddling.
This is real love, real listening,
real watching with circumstances.
- Yes, parenting is an art
and each child is different.
And how you balance, you
want to show the way,
but you don't want to interact
with their personal growth--
- 100%.
And this man can tell you as a parent,
you're only as happy as the
most unhappy child you have.
(Malik and Raz laugh)
Like you could have three,
he's got four of you guys,
right now, whoever's not in
the best place, even if they're
in a good place or a solid place,
that's what's running through their mind.
When you're navigating something,
when you're responsible,
same thing as me as a company.
I'm putting my finger in the
biggest holes in the boat.
There's a lot of holes.
If this trickles out, if this
clip, if this video catches
some vitality within the mainland
China audiences on Weibo,
WeChat, one thing I would tell parents is,
do a lot more listening,
and don't listen to your fucking friends.
(Malik and Raz laugh)
(Malik mumbles)
Listen to your kids.
And when I say listening, watch them,
what do they gravitate towards?
Nobody thought playing video
games 20 years ago was going to
lead to a luxurious financial
life, it clearly has.
- [Raz] True.
- So if you're so smart,
if you want your kids to be successful,
recognize that the world you live in today
has nothing to do with the
world they're going to live in,
nothing.
- [Raz] Yeah.
- And so I have empathy especially,
emerging middle classes.
But if you look at America as a proxy,
when the middle class started to emerge,
it was also when university
and college was starting
to build as a brand and it
worked for a period of time,
that was fine, but the
problem is technology
is too much of a variable.
Too much of a variable.
- Gary, I want to say something on this.
- [Gary] Please.
- We can talk of parents and parenting,
but I want to take the weight
off parents for a little bit
and talk a little bit
wider on the culture,
you know what I'm saying?
- China is going to be an
incredibly successful country
with a lot of unhappy people.
- [Raz] Interesting.
- 100%.
- So how do people kind of,
how do you kind of tell this audience,
because you got a lot
of people are going to
see these videos right now?
- Easy if you think money
is the root of happiness,
you're fucking broken, you've
lost, you've lost life.
You will not win.
- [Raz] Okay.
- That's my two cents.
- That's good.
- And listen,
- Solid there.
- I'm very empathetic.
I grew up in a culture very similar.
Like America has a lot of
those tendencies as well.
It's evolving, which is
why it will lose more,
but it will be in pockets, happier,
and everything's about balance, right?
Everything's about balance, if
the least hardworking country
or culture is over here and
if China plays over here,
the answer is always
somewhere in the middle.
Always, always, always, always.
And look, Israel is not
short of ambitious people
and hunger for success,
so you guys know this.
I mean, look from my standpoint,
that is China's vulnerability
is very easy, it's that.
I mean, if I wasn't aware of that,
this is the first time I'm consuming that.
If the default is I,
which for you to be rich.
So I'll give you an example.
I would argue that my grandmother
had that point of view,
and I don't think I know many people more,
not happy than my grandmother.
I'm thinking now the people
that like going through my mind,
that one I'm comfortable saying out loud,
because it's within my family.
I don't want to mention
the two or three people
I know in the business world, no question,
the least happy people I
know are the ones who look at
rich, money as the success barometer.
It leads to enormous insecurity.
- True.
- Yes.
- It's the same reason
fashion does so well
in mainland China.
If you think your YSL bag or
your Louis Baton or Supreme
is covering up two
winners your shortcomings,
you're fucking mistaken, you
might be tricking the masses,
but the top 10% of the world
knows everything they need
to know when you're fucking tricked out,
head to toe in Louis Vuitton.
The most insecure people
I know are also the people
that enjoy fashion cars,
planes, and watches the most.
- You cannot measure happiness,
and being rich is by number.
It's an internal issue.
- Yeah, but this pressure, I mean,
as a young person in China,
we got the pressure of,
we hearing successful stories
about kids in 25 years
and making billions and like,
and social media made it--
- Has nothing to do with you bruh.
- It's true, but it's just (mumbles).
- I get you, by the way, I get it.
You either succumb to it or you don't.
- [Malik] True.
- I get it, but again, back
to life is about options.
I'd rather kids today worry
about being successful because
that's what they're being
pushed versus worrying about how
to avoid the black plague or
run away from Eastern European,
Poland, 'cause they're Jewish
and they're about to get killed, right.
Or being sent off to the Korean war or,
I mean like, life's better.
I'm not going to shed
one fucking tear for you
because this is a prosperous,
happy world right now,
better than any other time.
And if your biggest fucking
worry is that you're going to
be judged by your neighbors and friends
because you didn't build
the next Instagram,
well fucking, you wanted.
(Raz and Malik laugh)
Really, I mean like listen, and I get it.
Everybody worries about
what they worry about.
I have friends who have $50
million in their trust fund
and all they worry about is
that nobody will ever think
they were good because
they were handed success,
and that their life is ruined
because they'll never be successful.
And by the way, I get it because
that wouldn't work for me.
That would've been really bad for me,
I would have struggled with that.
I worry that my kids have my
DNA and are going to struggle
with being on third base.
And so everybody has their own realities,
but here's the punchline my
friend, you have no choice.
Like it is what it is, it's
a good problem to have.
- Okay, that's that that's
kind of takes us into
the last topic I think it was
almost getting to 11:00 AM
and I know you're busy Gary.
So this in therapy,
we talked about in very
different social issues.
And in China, there is like
a thing on the internet.
It's something that started off very early
in education system in China,
but the way that people value
and judge somebody a lot
of times are related to a
concept of the three positives.
And that's something Malik
knows about (indistinct).
It's basically a combination of the three,
it's called (indistinct),
and the one is called a personal values.
Second life philosophy,
and third worldview.
Is the three views, is the
three kind of positives.
And a lot of times people
use this 'cause in China
because the political
environment is different.
- [Gary] Yes.
- It's a way to judge somebody's behavior,
whether he's more pro-woman
or pro-development,
or it's a way to judge
people's philosophies on life.
And a lot of times Malik
has used it 'cause he's kind
of he's a social, well,
he creates his opinion.
He puts out there, if we want
to tackle a social issue,
and he's known as like the
most, these three positives,
most correct of all,
like he is extremely
great example of this.
Now do you think people on the internet,
when they try to kind
of express themselves,
should they worry about how
people judge them constantly
on their values, is being a
person with really positive,
great values of life more
liberal vice, call it in the US?
Is that something that someone
should take when they're
trying to push themselves
through life and society?
Should be like pre prearranged
values in your system
or shouldn't you design it yourself?
- To expand on that.
- [Gary] Please.
- A lot of kids watch my stuff
and they believe I have a
good, like the values, but
I was actually tripped.
We're prisoned by these values,
I can not say stuff outside
of what is viewed to be right,
like the political correctness.
Sometimes I want to extend a little bit
and talk about different
ideas, different opinions,
but we know that there
are people who jump onto
the comment section and start firing about
you're not on the right
track, of you're not following
what is viewed to be right in the society.
I think like ignoring different
ideas and different voices,
it's really dangerous.
- [Raz] Young peoples
push off to be kind of.
- Here's my two cents on this.
The biggest thing that you
guys don't know that we know
as the older statesman in
the room is that the state of
politically correct views
changes all the time.
- [Paps] True.
- What he grew up with,
what I then grew up with,
it's changed, to me, I don't sit on,
I am the most pro-human
person, the thought I would die
if I was to suppress another human being
in any shape or form, for
me to judge or do something
negative to another human
being literally breaks my soul.
Like the thought is so foreign.
Like I can't even
comprehend the ability to.
When I watch the world or
my friends or neighbors
or associates or politicians
on the world stage,
America, Russia, China, anywhere.
It's the single worst thing you can do,
especially in today's environment
where everything's being documented.
You will lose historically,
your legacy will be tainted.
So for me, I could
never do the wrong thing
by another person, however, I
do not take the liberal point
of view on every social issue.
I do not believe that, I
believe that we've gone too far
in America by giving kids trophies
if they come in fifth place.
I'm just not, I don't have
the liberal point of view.
I do not believe in unions, that is not,
I don't think that that's a good idea.
I think taking the fair
market out of it is bad.
I come from the Soviet Union,
I know what happens when
you go too far, right?
I think that there's a
lot of laziness in China
that people don't talk about
because of those undertones
in certain, especially if
they aren't just emerging
in the middle class, they
started at the, right?
So I think you will lose if you are scared
to put out your true set,
here's the number one thing
I will tell you, for you and
anybody else who's listening,
who's playing in this game.
When you die on a sword,
it's much more fun
to die on your own sword.
So when you lose by living
a public life on an issue
that you didn't fully
believe in to begin with,
it's going to hurt double.
- [Paps] I agree.
- As far as people leaving comments,
that doesn't even penetrate my mindset.
And both ways, both ways,
most of my comments is,
"I'm the greatest,
I'm the greatest human
being that ever lived,
I'm the greatest," it doesn't penetrate.
Just as much as somebody saying,
"I'm wrong or I'm a
charlatan, or they hate me,"
both the same, which is I'm
appreciative anybody's paying
attention to the begin with, I'm grateful.
And that's where it kind
of stops and starts.
Somebody anonymous on the
internet saying I suck
or that I'm, you know
better than that, really?
- Yeah, I know my one cent is don't live
by others people comment, at
the same time, listen to them.
- Always, always, you
have to be thoughtful.
You can never get too
high in your own supply.
And that's, I was saying
the same thing, which is,
whether they say I'm the
greatest or I'm the worst,
it's one in the same, and I
think people are selective.
They love the positive feedback
and they block the negative feedback.
I probably spend a little more
time on the negative feedback
than the positive feedback,
because I want to be thoughtful
and I never want to become a
caricature of myself where I'm
getting too high on myself.
But I also don't over stress
around the negative feedback
because I'm empathetic,
I understand why they're
giving it to me, go ahead.
- So yeah, another actual
question I want to ask
for myself and also a lot of--
- True we can go a
couple of minutes into--
- People doing it here, we
talked a lot about China,
but what about New York?
So kids like me or foreign
kids, fresh out of boat,
we want to make it here,
especially in New York,
everybody dreams about New York.
What does it take to make it in New York?
- I think it takes the same
thing that it takes to make it
in Beijing or anywhere
in the world, Tel Aviv,
it's the same old game.
You have to assess the situation.
You have to understand
what value you can provide.
And you have to understand
what your ambitions
and goals are, I mean, look,
I think that places like New
York or London or Tel-Aviv for
that matter or Beijing,
Shanghai and on and on, and on.
These are special places, this
is where a lot of people are.
This is where the A-plus talent
is and it's congregating.
And every situation is different.
I think the one great thing America has
is it's got a lot of shortcomings,
like any part of the world.
But the government intervention
on entrepreneurship
and capitalism is far less,
which creates a much
more even playing field,
which is an awfully exciting
and intoxicating feeling,
just this, hey just this.
I think where American
businessmen and women get confused
about being successful in China,
and I've watched so many of them,
and it must be funny for you actually,
going through that transition,
watching everybody come in
with a lot of puffy chest
and getting annihilated is
they underestimate the market.
They underestimate the
skillset of the people
and the actual pure bred entrepreneurship,
but what they also
underestimate is the government,
period, end of story.
I have the luxury of being born in a place
where that was very much the case,
so it's always been in
the back of my mind.
China's not America.
You have to be very thoughtful
of your relationships
with the government or you
will not succeed at the level
that you decide you're
going to succeed at,
or more importantly, it sucks
you into a certain level
and then it really hurts your feelings.
So I think making it in New
York for somebody in China,
who's a young kid, fresh off the boat
is very exciting because some
of the things that they've
always thought were in play
are actually not a negative
in this market and that's
obviously very exciting.
- Great, thank you.
- Yeah,
you do have the China
card, even in New York?
- [Malik] Yeah.
- You get to play your advantages.
- [Malik] True.
- Whatever you do, people
who are born there,
they have friends and
they're saying things
you don't understand,
you have a shortcoming,
but do you have a card.
- The value added, right,
so like bring what you have
to here instead of like similar.
- Brother it's huge, the
amount of A and B list
business people I know that are desperate
to form relationships within
the US with Chinese kids,
luminaries, influencers,
KOLs, business people.
The biggest reason that I'm
not building my brand in China
is time, the time of being on the ground.
And so there's a lot of
people who have that issue.
It's an enormous advantage to
be able to speak the dialect.
Anybody who right now can
speak both those languages
is off to the fucking races.
And the reality is, there's
a hell of a lot more Chinese
that are able to do it than
Americans for now, right?
That will change over the
next 20 years as we start
introducing it way more
into the education system
and education in America changes.
Most of the kids I know
that are eight, nine, 10,
that can speak Mandarin,
are not doing it within their school,
they're doing it outside of their school.
And so I think we'll see more
of that as Americans realize
that's a cost of entry
to win on a global stage.
Unless technology catches up,
I actually think by the time
we teach everybody in translation,
we've got it in our ear.
Like, I think I'm sorry.
- [Malik] Could have happened.
- But it goes to the soft skill.
Understanding the
culture is more important
than the language.
- Always, always.
- The culture,
so you have a really good
followup question, Gary.
This really, really
important for us 'cause.
So we have talking, we have
duet influenced in China.
We built it with a lot of
empathy, patience and time.
We didn't just go viral like this.
- [Gary] Of course not.
- We were, I think his story, my story,
he's one of the dorms here in New York,
trying to make videos and
slowly as I should building
different kinds of formats.
And it took us time and
patience to enter China
and show them the foreigner
point of view about China,
that's what we do.
Our main selling point in China
is that we show for Chinese
people how we enjoy or appreciate or think
of different Chinese trends.
- [Gary] I understand.
- This is there has been
very great, however,
my bigger dream, personal
dream is I want to,
I think that the world is so
much more open to more people
to see this country itself
instead of the Chinese people.
- [Gary] Couldn't agree any more.
- So our biggest dream is to
bring it here to Facebook,
YouTube, Instagram, to show more people,
what is life in China like, and
then we build a brand called
Ychina with capital Y, Ychina.
But again, as you said to enter
a new market, a new place,
it takes, the person, I
grew up 10 years in China,
I'm completely non-westernized
in many of my thinking.
I haven't been involved
in Facebook as much as,
I have been spending 99% of my time
on Chinese social networks and 1%.
- [Gary] Of course.
- So would that time and empathy
needed to enter this market
with our content to show the
world, show Americans per se,
what he's trying to like,
what are things that attract
Americans about China
that are currently relevant,
can be in the next two, three years?
What are the main topics that
you think I should spend time
exploring, I don't want to
do everything, (mumbles)?
- So look, I think the
biggest problem with America
is it's so American biased, right?
- [Malik] Yes.
- America's biggest shortcoming
is that it's been the leader
of the world for too long,
and it's gotten high off its own supply.
America's answer to anything
when somebody else is doing
something well, is that
they're cheating or corrupt.
It's a very big, very big vulnerability.
I think the reason I love the Olympics,
the reason I love social media,
like open communication
solves every issue.
Like it's just true.
So to me, I just think it's the truth.
I think what you need to do if
you want that is you need to
become the practitioner and
the executer in a YouTube,
Facebook, Instagram,
Snapchat, podcast world,
the same way you are in
a Weibo, WeChat world.
So to me, I don't think
it's about the content.
I think as long as you
tell the truth, I mean,
people are fascinated
by you just, I think...
Well, let me give you a
couple of things I would do.
I would definitely do
interviewing people on the street
around things that are
happening in America.
A video that would do very
well in the US on social media
is a one minute video mashup
of seven people's answers
on Instagram of what people in
China think about Instagram.
And you doing the clever
job of showing seven people
that never heard of it, or
seven people talking about
what they loved when they
did a semester at UCLA.
So I think taking content
that is happening in the US,
like asking, I think 40
people for three minutes
answering their thoughts
on LeBron James in China
is an interesting insight.
So taking things that are
trending in America and asking
and making videos one
to five minute videos
of normal Chinese citizens, young and old
giving their two cents, if
you call it like two yen,
or something like that, it
would be really interesting
for Americans to see the
perception of their brands
and culture outside.
- You're right on, because
what's got Raz so popular
in China is the fact he was
talking about things trending.
- [Gary] 100%.
- 'Cause actually the flip
mirror, this will go--
- [Gary] 100%.
- Yeah, okay, and then what
about some else you want
to split up, I'm gonna use
the time everything we've got.
Vox-Vice, they make this
kind of internal more deep,
more informative, but also be realistic
like documentaries, right?
And we actually did some
shows showing me working
in Chinese beams, a Chinese
delivery boy working
in Chinese trains don't use new year.
I was being very documentary level,
like really trying heavily to
show people the real life that
is that also the direction
that the Americans would like
to see or is this things are less?
- Humans want to see truth,
that's why documentaries work.
- [Raz] Right.
- That's why new platforms
when they emerge,
documentaries always over index.
That's why Netflix is
doing so well with them.
The truth always wins.
And then we start melting
it and make it less truth,
but the truth is always the answer.
- Okay, yeah, they could be
performing better on Facebook
than our interviews videos,
but again, just like.
- Don't get caught up in short
term social media analytics
as an indicator to what works.
My YouTube channel views on my daily blog
haven't moved in a year by
all metrics, not working.
I'm just completely unfazed.
I'm aware because I pay
attention to my shit,
but I'm not going to pander
to creating something that
doesn't feel authentic to
me to get 200,000 views
per episode instead of 50,
that has no value in the long game.
- [Raz] Just stick to ourselves,
be real, do our content.
- It's always going to be the best answer.
All right, I gotta run, thank you guys.
- Thank you so much.
(uplifting upbeat music)